>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
[Musik]
Ich stelle mein eigenes Olivenöl her.
Das habt ihr vielleicht schon mitbekommen.
Wir beschäftigen uns auch schon
seit über zwei Jahren mit Olivenölen
und haben uns dann dazu entschieden,
das eigene Olivenöl herzustellen.
Zum einen weiß ich, was drin steckt,
und zum anderen habe ich wirklich
so viel über Olivenöl erfahren,
zum Beispiel auch, dass Olivenöl zu den Lebensmitteln gehört,
die am meisten gefälscht werden.
Wie und warum erzähle ich euch aber später.
Wir sind jetzt hier gerade in Aydın in der Türkei.
Und Aydın ist auch dafür bekannt,
dass es wirklich große Olivenhaine hat.
Hier können die Olivenbäume wirklich supergut wachsen,
direkt hier oben auf dem Berg.
Man hat immer so eine leichte Prise vom Wind,
vom Meer natürlich auch.
Und ich benötige natürlich jemanden, dem ich vertrauen kann.
So haben wir auch vor einigen Jahren
den Mahmut kennengelernt.
Ihn werdet ihr später im Video auch noch sehen.
Und jetzt, würde ich sagen, nehme ich euch einfach mit rüber
zu den restlichen Olivenbäumen.
Die werden wir jetzt
gemeinsam mit den fleißigen Helfern ernten.
Und dann zeige ich euch und erzähle euch,
warum die Frühernte so wichtig ist.
[Musik]
Jetzt geht es an die Olivenernte.
Und, damit man hier auch keinen Sonnenstich bekommt,
schön ein Kopftuch aufziehen.
Evet en aydınlı oldum.
Und dann noch so.
Ready!
Das Olivenöl aus der Frühernte ist deshalb so gesund,
weil in grünen Oliven ganz viele Polyphenole stecken.
Das sind sekundäre Pflanzenstoffe,
die nachweislich gesundheitsfördernd sind.
Das heißt, sie können entzündungshemmend sein,
das Risiko für Herz-Kreislauf-Erkrankungen
und für Krebs lindern.
Sie können den Blutdruck regulieren.
Und wir benutzen wirklich nur Oliven aus der Frühernte,
damit unser Olivenöl das beste auf der Welt ist.
Und ich habe auch mein traditionelles Ernteoutfit an.
Denn bei der Ernte muss man zum einen flexibel sein.
Das ist eine richtig bequeme Hose,
Şalvar genannt.
Die muss ich mir unbedingt mit nach Deutschland nehmen.
[Musik]
Und wir haben hier den Garten gepachtet,
da er wirklich nur sortenrein ist
und wir wirklich nur Oliven aus einer reinen Sorte haben.
Jetzt fragt man sich vielleicht:
Warum stellt denn nicht die ganze Welt
Olivenöl aus der Frühernte her?
Es hat einen ganz einfachen Grund,
nämlich den finanziellen Grund.
Wenn das Ganze vergleicht,
kann man aus 7 bis 9 Kilo grüner, unreifer Oliven
etwa einen Liter reines Olivenöl aus der Frühernte herstellen.
Vergleicht man das jetzt mit reifen Oliven,
die wirklich bis Februar oder März reifen durften,
dann braucht man etwa nur 3 Kilo,
um einen Liter Olivenöl herzustellen.
Und so hat man bei der Frühernte
wirklich nur ein Drittel des Ernteertrages.
Und das geht natürlich auch auf die Kosten.
Also man könnte auch, wenn man wollte,
konventionelles Olivenöl, was es im Supermarkt gibt,
gar nicht in der Frühernte machen,
weil es gar nicht so viele Olivenbäume
auf der ganzen Welt gibt.
Und, weil die Industrie natürlich
immer ganz viel Geld machen möchte
und irgendwo auch machen muss,
strecken sie ihr Olivenöl,
lassen die Oliven ganz reif werden.
Und das ist eben das, was das Olivenöl
später eben nicht mehr so ganz gesund macht.
Wir haben gesagt, wir konzentrieren uns auf die Frühernte,
wir wollen das beste Olivenöl der Welt herstellen.
Und das machen wir hier auch.
[Musik]
Die Olivenbäume werden übrigens auch nicht gespritzt.
Also es ist wirklich alles supernatürlich.
Um aber trotzdem Schädlinge wegzuhalten,
hat man hier diese Flaschen aufgehängt.
Das habt ihr vielleicht schon bemerkt.
An jedem Baum hängt so eine Flasche.
Und zwar sind in dieser Flasche Pheromone drin.
Es gibt nämlich die berühmt-berüchtigte Olivenfliege.
Und die frisst sich wirklich in die Olive rein,
zerstört zum einen die Geschmacksstoffe
und zum anderen frisst sie natürlich
auch die Polyphenole raus.
Deswegen sind hier Pheromone drin.
Die Weibchen, also die Fliegenweibchen
werden damit erst gar nicht angelockt.
Die bleiben schön weg.
Und die Männchen, die fliegen da rein
und werden so bekämpft.
So wie in der Natur,
dass die Weibchen einfach schlau sind
und die Gefahr wittern und wegbleiben
und die Männer, die tappen leider in die Falle.
>> JOSH: Das finde ich jetzt ein bisschen unfair.
>> SALLY: Das finde ich gar nicht unfair.
Ich meine, alles, was gut riecht und gut aussieht,
das zieht doch Männer an, oder?
>> MURAT: Ich suche mir einen anderen Baum.
>> SALLY: Und ich fliege weg.
[Musik]
Damit das wertvolle Polyphenol in den Oliven bleibt,
ist natürlich wichtig, dass man sie sorgfältig eben auch erntet.
Falls die Oliven doch aber mal leicht beschädigt werden,
durch einen Kratzer zum Beispiel,
werden die Oliven direkt nach der Ernte,
also wirklich drei- bis viermal am Tag sogar,
direkt zur Pressstation gefahren,
damit eben das Olivenöl qualitativ hochwertig ist.
Die Damen hier dürfen jetzt eine kurze Pause machen.
Und ich habe mir gedacht,
wir überraschen sie jetzt einfach in ihrer Mittagspause
und machen einen türkischen, traditionellen Folkloretanz.
[Musik]
Also ich weiß jetzt nicht so ganz,
was Olivenöl mit dem Folkloretanz zu tun hat,
aber vielen Dank, Volkan.
>> MURAT: Ja.
Volkan, vielen Dank, dass ich das machen muss.
Ich habe mir das schon immer gewünscht.
>> SALLY: Oh, ich weiß! Damit...
>> MURAT: Aber es hat... Genau.
>> SALLY: Damit die Ernte ertragreich wird!
>> MURAT: Genau. Nicht nur, dass die Ernte ertragreich wird,
und zwar Folgendes:
Die Folklore
>> SALLY: Folklore.
>> MURAT: – genau – nennt sich Zeybek.
Und Zeybek, das ist ein Tanz von Kriegern,
die auf den Bergen wohnten oder lebten.
Und das waren wirkliche Krieger.
Da, ich habe auch meinen Dolch hier.
Und die haben getanzt.
Und jeder Tanz, jeder Zeybek-Tanz
erzählt eigentlich eine Geschichte.
Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt tanzen werde mit dir,
>> SALLY: Dann erzähl es.
>> MURAT: werden wir eine Geschichte erzählen.
>> SALLY: Die Geschichte von Murat und Sally.
>> MURAT: Ja.
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Die Netze wurden hier vorher aufgespannt,
damit eben nur ganz frische Oliven,
die frisch vom Baum kommen, hier eben auch reinfallen
und so geerntet werden können.
[Musik]
>> ERNTEHELFERIN: Yeğenlerim var Almanya'da
>> SALLY: Öyle mi?
>> ERNTEHELFERIN: Evet.
>> SALLY: Almanya'nın neresınde?
>> ERNTEHELFERIN: Osnabrück'te.
>> SALLY: In Osnabrück hat sie Nichten und Neffen
und die grüßt sie ganz lieb.
Das wird jetzt hier alles noch sortiert.
Das heißt, hier kommt jetzt das ganze Laub erst mal weg,
die guten Oliven kommen hier in die Kisten
und dann gehen sie direkt zum Pressen.
Ja.
Schatz, wenn es so weitergeht und ich das allein mache,
dann wird das Öl nie fertig.
>> MURAT: Das muss schon mal weg.
>> SALLY: Das Kaputte muss raus, das Laub muss raus.
>> MURAT: Da sieht man mal,
wie viel Arbeit dahintersteckt, gell?
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> MURAT: Also das ist nicht so zack, zack, zack.
[Musik]
Wenn du kaputte Oliven findest,
>> SALLY: Ja, die sortiere ich aus.
>> MURAT: die nicht reinmachen, sortier sie aus.
Weil die kaputten geben wir dann Bertolli.
Dam-da-dam-da-daa-da-daa,
daa-daa-da-dam-da-daa!
>> SALLY: Stimmt. Da sitzt keiner und sortiert Oliven.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Die nehmen alles, Blätter, Oliven,
>> SALLY: kaputte.
>> MURAT: Ich glaube, wenn jeder mal
beim Bauern arbeiten würde,
hier bei der Olivenernte oder beim Karottenbauern
oder beim Gemüsebauern,
einmal einen Tag mal wirklich drin arbeiten würde,
würden wir Lebensmittel viel mehr wertschätzen
und auch den Preis dahinter.
Und man würde selber auf die Schliche kommen,
dass manche Produkte,
vor allem Lebensmittel,
völlig unter Preis verkauft werden.
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Komm, Murat.
Ich habe noch Platz.
>> MURAT: So.
>> SALLY: Und jetzt fahren wir gemeinsam
zum Olivenölpressen, okay?
>> MURAT: Ja.
Drück mal ein bisschen dagegen.
Drück, Sally.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Ich komme übrigens
aus einer Gewichtheberfamilie.
>> SALLY: Du kannst schon loslassen.
Ich habe die Bolzen drin.
>> MURAT: Ach so, okay.
Ich wollte immer Famer werden,
jetzt bin ich Farmer.
>> SALLY: Na los!
[Musik]
Ja. Und vor zwei Jahren
haben wir dann den Mahmut kennengelernt
bei uns zu Hause.
Und er hat sich vorgestellt
und da haben wir gleich gemerkt, okay, es passt einfach,
vom Charakter her, vom Typ her,
von der Person her und auch vom Herzen her.
Aber das erzählt er euch jetzt gleich selber.
>> MAHMUT: Hallo, Sally.
>> SALLY: Hello!
>> SALLY: Ich glaube, jetzt wisst ihr,
warum wir mit Mahmut zusammenarbeiten.
Er macht es aus Leidenschaft,
wir machen es aus Leidenschaft.
>> MURAT: Er hat einen Dachschaden.
>> SALLY: Und das passt einfach.
>> MURAT: Er hat einen richtigen Dachschaden.
>> SALLY: Ja, aber wir auch.
>> MURAT: Ja, genau.
Und anders geht es eigentlich nicht.
Um so was zu entwickeln, zu machen,
braucht man einen gewissen Dachschaden.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Und man muss auch
mit einer gewissen Naivität drangehen.
Weil dann lernt man alles besser
und man hinterfragt auch alles.
>> SALLY: Ja. Und vor allem geht es uns einfach drum,
das beste Olivenöl der Welt zu machen,
euren Horizont zu erweitern
und das Bewusstsein bei den Menschen zu wecken
für gesunde Lebensmittel.
>> MURAT: Was ich auch noch sagen möchte, ist:
Man sagt immer: "Das ist das beste Olivenöl der Welt!"
Wir haben gar nicht alle Olivenöle der Welt probiert,
muss man sagen.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Aber für uns
das bestmögliche, was es überhaupt gibt.
Oder? Richtig gesagt?
>> SALLY: Ja, richtig.
>> MURAT: Genau.
Ja.
>> SALLY: Du musst immer das letzte Wort haben.
>> MURAT: Ist mir auch gerade aufgefallen.
>> SALLY: Weil ich habe
so einen schönen Abschluss gemacht
und dann musst du immer das letzte Wort haben.
>> MURAT: Okay. Dann gehen wir weiter.
Tschüss!
>> SALLY: Nicht tschüss.
Wir machen noch das Video weiter.
>> MURAT: Ach so, wir machen das Video weiter.
Ja. Dann gehen wir jetzt in die Produktion.
>> SALLY: Du musst es nicht moderieren.
Wir schneiden es.
>> MURAT: Ach so, wir schneiden es. Okay.
Gehen wir jetzt rüber in die Produktion?
Kann ich das jetzt zeigen?
>> SALLY: Der Dreh ist so anstrengend mit dir!
>> MURAT: Ja, dann geht es halt weiter.
>> SALLY: Also wir sind jetzt hier direkt.
Fünf Stunden hat es jetzt etwa gedauert
von der Ernte bis hierher.
Ich habe mich übrigens umgezogen.
Denn mein Şalvar ist leider gerissen.
Zum Glück hatte ich noch eine Hose dabei.
Und jetzt sind wir hier und pressen die Oliven direkt.
Und ich habe euch ja gesagt,
dass Olivenöl einfach viel mit Vertrauen zu tun hat.
Und der Mahmut kontrolliert hier wirklich alles
und sorgt auch dafür, dass mein Olivenöl
wirklich nur von unseren Bäumen stammt,
dass es sortenrein ist
und dass es wirklich aus unserem einzigen Garten ist,
Tek Bahçe.
Und, weil jetzt gerade die Chili-Saison ist,
haben wir Chilis aus İzmir, nämlich Jalapeños.
Die sind auch schön rot
und sorgen gleich für eine schöne rote Farbe im Chili-Olivenöl.
Denn wir haben gesagt,
wir machen einmal ein normales Olivenöl
und ein Chili-Olivenöl
und nutzen jetzt eben die Chili-Saison aus.
Jetzt stellen wir erst mal dieses her
und später noch ein anderes Olivenöl, ein reines Olivenöl.
>> MAHMUT: Danke schön.
>> SALLY: Başlayalım!
>> MAHMUT: Let's start!
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Nach der Reinigung
werden die Oliven schonend zerkleinert
und dieser entstandene Oliventeig
wird dann ganz vorsichtig geknetet,
sodass langsam das Öl aus den Oliven austritt.
Das Öl wird dann noch mehrfach gefiltert,
damit die Schwebstoffe einfach entfernt werden.
Danach kommt das gefilterte Olivenöl dann in große Tanks,
wo es einfach eine Zeit lang ruhen darf
und die darin vorhanden Schwebstoffe
sich noch absetzen können,
damit es danach
nach der endgültigen Filterung richtig rein ist.
Ich werde jetzt die Zwischenzeit nutzen und euch zeigen,
wo ich meine Olivenölflaschen herstellen lasse.
Wir fahren jetzt nämlich gemeinsam nach İznik.
Wir haben uns nämlich dazu entschlossen,
Keramikflaschen selber zu machen
in verschiedenen Designs.
Und da nehme ich euch jetzt mal mit.
Jetzt machen wir mal unser Olivenöl-Tasting.
>> MURAT: Und da gibt es auch Dinge,
die ihr beachten müsst beim Tasting.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Ihr könnt übrigens,
wenn ihr das Band später irgendwann mal wegmacht,
könnt ihr das Nazar Boncuk, also das Auge,
einfach an eure Kette dranhängen als Anhänger.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Oder ans Armband.
>> MURAT: Und die Flasche als Vase benutzen.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Oder nach eurem Ehepartner werfen.
>> SALLY: Ah!
>> MURAT: Doch, kann man auch.
>> SALLY: Viel zu schade!
>> MURAT: Ja. Tut auch weh.
>> SALLY: Also ihr füllt euer Olivenöl in so ein kleines Glas.
Er sagt, normalerweise nimmt man schwarze Gläser dafür.
Dann auf Handwärme erwärmen
Dran riechen.
Und dann riecht man echt die Natur,
das Gras, die Bäume.
Also man riecht alles da raus.
Das ist tatsächlich so.
Und dann
probieren und im Mund
– also nicht gleich schlucken,
sondern im Mund so ein bisschen umherwälzen.
Und dann habt ihr wirklich
die verschiedenen Geschmacksbereiche,
also so ein bisschen
fruchtig...
>> MURAT: Ja, vorne an der Zunge merkt man
>> MURAT & SALLY: dieses Fruchtige.
>> SALLY: Dann seitlich das Bittere.
Und dann schlucken.
Und im Abgang wird es scharf.
Und das kommt durch die Antioxidantien
und die Polyphenole zustande.
Okay.
>> MURAT: Also erst...
Ich finde, bei mir, wenn ich es auf der Zunge habe,
dann schmeckt das so nussig.
Ich glaube, ich habe mir die Hände nicht gewaschen.
Ha! Der war gut, gell?
Okay, weiter geht's.
>> SALLY: Oh, ich finde es voll lecker!
Und im Hals
kratzt das dann auch so richtig.
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: Und man muss oft davon husten.
Vielleicht, was noch wichtig zu erwähnen wäre:
Ich meine, bei uns brennt das jetzt auch im Hals.
Wir trinken es ja auch gerade pur.
Macht man ja im Alltag normalerweise nicht.
Also, wenn ihr das Öl dann später
für Salate, für das Essen,
für Dressings,
zum Kochen oder Backen verwendet,
dann brennt es natürlich nicht.
Das ist jetzt nur, weil wir es pur probieren.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Denn es integriert sich wirklich
wunderbar in alle Speisen.
Mmh!
>> MURAT: Das war das Chiliöl.
>> SALLY: Also eins kann ich sagen:
Das Chiliöl, das brennt.
>> MURAT: Ja, okay.
Und das Geile ist...
>> SALLY: Eine gute Schärfe.
>> MURAT: Hier ist es ganz cool.
Also ich mag das Chiliöl
– das sind alles Sachen, wo ein bisschen würziger sind,
also gerade beim Fleischanbraten oder so was.
Wirklich! Ihr habt richtig gehört.
Fleisch anbraten, das ist gar kein Problem mit diesem Öl.
>> MAHMUT: Oh!
Sol.
>> MURAT: Ja. Das ist echt scharf, gell?
>> MAHMUT: Schon ein bisschen.
>> MURAT: Hm.
Aber es ist der Wahnsinn!
>> SALLY: Oh! Das über eine Pizza oder so.
>> MURAT: Ja. Genau, eine
– au, cool!
Pizza nehmen und einfach über die Pizza drüber machen.
>> MAHMUT: Lahmacun.
>> MURAT: Wahnsinn!
>> SALLY: Mmh! >> MURAT: Lahmacun? Woah!
>> MAHMUT: Wahnsinn! Wahnsinn!
>> MURAT: He!
Wahnsinn! Genau!
Jawoll!
Jawoll! Wir bringen ihm noch Deutsch bei.
>> MAHMUT: Ich schwöre, Wahnsinn!
>> MURAT: Ja!
>> SALLY: Aber vielleicht kann man das
jetzt gerade dazu sagen.
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: Olivenöl darf man nämlich erhitzen.
Das ist ja auch so ein Mythos, den es gibt,
dass man sagt, Olivenöl darf nicht erhitzt werden
wegen des Rauchpunkts.
Es ist aber so, wenn ihr ein naturtrübes Olivenöl habt
– unseres ist also nicht naturtrüb, sondern wir filtern es ja,
damit diese Schwebstoffe entfernt werden können
und das Olivenöl zum einen länger haltbar ist,
und zum anderen habt ihr dann
auch einen höheren Rauchpunkt.
Also ein ganz klares, ganz fein gefiltertes Olivenöl
kann immer erhitzt werden,
ist eigentlich sogar das beste Fett zum Erhitzen,
weil es wirklich einen sehr hohen Rauchpunkt hat,
so 180 bis 220°C ungefähr.
Und bei Olivenöl ist es sogar so,
dass sogar bei 160°C schon frittiert werden kann,
anders als bei anderen Ölen.
Die muss man nämlich wirklich bis 180°C erwärmen.
Also da müssen wir den Mythos aus dem Weg räumen
und sagen: Wer qualitativ gutes Olivenöl hat,
der kann es auch erhitzen.
>> MURAT: Die ältesten Menschen übrigens
aus Europa, die kommen aus Griechenland und aus Italien.
Es ist wirklich so.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> MURAT: Das liegt an der gesunden Ernährung.
Und glaubt mir:
Die Griechen, die Italiener und die Türken,
die tun alles mit Olivenöl machen.
Richtig?
>> SALLY: Ja, alles.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Sogar Kuchen backen.
>> MURAT: Kuchen backen sogar mit Olivenöl.
>> SALLY & MURAT: Ja.
>> MURAT: Habt keine Angst davor.
>> SALLY: Wir sind jetzt hier in İznik angekommen,
wo unsere Keramikflaschen fürs Olivenöl hergestellt werden.
İznik gehört zur Provinz Bursa.
Hier gibt es auch den İznik-See.
Das ist der fünftgrößte See hier in der Türkei.
Und wir lassen die Keramikflaschen herstellen,
weil wir einfach etwas ganz Besonderes
für das Olivenöl haben wollten.
Wir wollten keine Glasflaschen,
weil man die ja nach der Benutzung meist wegschmeißt.
Und unsere Olivenölflasche, die Keramikflasche,
die ist so schön.
Ich habe gesagt, da kann man sich wirklich schön
dieses hochwertige Olivenöl einfach in die Küche stellen
als Dekoration, als Geschenkartikel mitnehmen.
Und vor allem verwendet man sie
auch nach der Benutzung, wenn die Flasche leer ist,
noch weiter als Vase
oder kann sie noch mal befüllen mit anderen Lebensmitteln.
Und die wird hier direkt hergestellt,
weil İznik dafür bekannt ist,
dass sie eben Ton und Keramik herstellen.
Den Ton bekommt man hier direkt vor Ort.
Hier die Erde eignet sich perfekt zum Tonherstellen.
Und vor allem unterstützen wir hier
einfach die Menschen vor Ort.
Ich zeige euch jetzt hier unsere Werkstatt
und zeige euch, wie unsere Keramikflasche hergestellt wird.
[Musik]
Hier haben wir jetzt den natürlichen Rohstoff, das ist Ton.
Das ist einfach Sand, der verfeinert wird mit Mineralien,
damit er eben die perfekte Konsistenz erhält.
Hier unterscheidet man zwischen weißem und rotem Ton.
Wir verwenden den weißen Ton für unsere Flaschen.
Und der wird jetzt einfach nur mit Wasser vermischt.
Das passiert hier in einem großen Mixer,
damit eben eine schöne Konsistenz entsteht,
mit der wir dann gleich die Flaschen gießen können.
Hier entsteht also der Teig.
Sieht richtig schön aus,
wie so eine riesengroße KitchenAid,
so eine Küchenmaschine.
[Musik]
Ich fühle mich gerade wie in meiner Backstube.
Und hier habe ich das Negativ.
So entsteht unsere Keramikflasche.
Das sind zwei Teile
und der Boden.
Und im Boden haben wir unser Logo eingearbeitet.
Und hier nutzt man einfach
die natürlichen Eigenschaften von Gips.
Gips...
Hat er sich den Kopf angestoßen?
Hier nutzen wir einfach
die natürlichen Eigenschaften von Gips.
Gips zieht nämlich Feuchtigkeit auf.
Und ich zeige euch das auch gleich.
Denn so erkennt der Meister dann,
ob die Form eben trocken genug ist.
Also hier werden drei Teile zusammengebaut.
Und jetzt kann ich hier die flüssige Masse einfüllen.
[Musik]
Das erinnert mich jetzt wirklich ganz stark
ans Schokoladenkörperherstellen.
Denn ich habe jetzt hier meine temperierte Schokolade,
meine Negative zum Hohlkörperherstellen.
Und so ist es wirklich auch.
Also mit dem Trichter
kann ich jetzt den flüssigen Ton hier einfüllen,
hier randvoll.
[Musik]
Hier habe ich ja jetzt keinen Hohlkörper,
sondern einen Vollkörper.
Denn die Form ist ja vollgegossen mit Ton.
Und der Ton darf jetzt hier erst mal aushärten.
Der Gips zieht die Feuchtigkeit raus.
Und der Meister hier erkennt dann anhand dieser Gipsform,
ob genug Feuchtigkeit rausgezogen wurde.
Und am nächsten Tag
kann dann die Form ausgegossen werden.
Das heißt, diese hier lasse ich jetzt heute hier stehen.
Aber der Usta hat jetzt schon
– also der Meister hat jetzt schon Formen vorbereitet
von gestern und die lösen wir jetzt kurz raus,
also gießen den Überschuss raus.
[Musik]
Für mich ist das gerade total der Meditationsort.
Also ich komme hier voll zur Ruhe.
Ich glaube, wenn man mal Urlaub braucht
und so den ganzen Stress loswerden will,
kommt man hierher zum Töpfern.
Und jetzt kommt der aufregende Part.
Denn mein Hohlkörper ist jetzt fertig und wird herausgelöst.
Ich zeige es euch mal.
Ich bin etwas aufgeregt.
Vorsichtig hinlegen.
Und das wird so mit jeder einzelnen Flasche gemacht.
Zuerst den Boden weg.
[Musik]
Wenn die Flaschen getrocknet sind, sehen sie so aus.
Wunderschön!
Natürlich deutlich heller, weil die Feuchtigkeit weg ist.
Aber so sind sie noch nicht fertig.
Jetzt werden sie erst mal geglättet.
Das heißt, hier die Naht wird mit einem Messer entfernt,
mit dem Messerrücken.
Da muss man echt ganz vorsichtig arbeiten,
um nicht zu viel Material mit abzukratzen.
Und dann schön mit Schleifpapier komplett abschleifen.
[Musik]
So ist jetzt die Flasche komplett glatt,
aber ihr seht auch hier schon so kleine Luftlöcher,
kleine Macken.
Die kann ich jetzt noch mal mit Ton ein bisschen auffüllen,
trocknen lassen, drüberschleifen.
Und dann ist sie wirklich perfekt.
>> MURAT: Bin ich jetzt fertig?
>> SALLY: Nee, du bist noch nicht fertig.
Bleib noch ein bisschen.
Ich fühle mich gerade wie die Super-Nanny
und der Murat sitzt auf der stillen Treppe
als Disziplinarmaßnahme.
>> MURAT: Was kochst du mir jetzt dafür?
>> SALLY: Er hat es sich ausgesucht.
Perfekt!
Jetzt ist der ganze Staub entfernt.
Und jetzt können die Tonflaschen endlich in den Backofen,
damit sie richtig fest werden.
Und dann geht es zum nächsten Step,
nämlich zum Bemalen.
Das wird mein erstes Mal Töpfern.
Ich hoffe, es gelingt mir ansatzweise eine Form.
Okay.
Das wird!
Ich brauche nur mehr Wasser.
Das wird eine individuelle Vase.
[Musik]
Spielen wir jetzt Ghost?
>> MURAT: Ja.
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Aber nicht, dass das jetzt schmuddelig wird.
>> MURAT: Wenn es schmuddelig wird, höre ich sofort auf.
Ich sage es dir, ich gehe dann weg.
Meine Mutter guckt bestimmt zu.
>> SALLY: Achtung! Achtung!
>> MURAT: Cool!
>> SALLY: Ja.
Ja, doch.
So.
Und dann noch mal ein bisschen höher ziehen.
Beschützt meine Vase!
Die Welt geht unter, aber beschützt meine Vase!
Stellt euch hin wie eine Mauer!
Danke schön!
Oh!
>> SARAH: Schnell runter!
>> SALLY: Schnell weg! Schnell weg!
Puh!
[Musik]
Hier sind wir jetzt in der zweiten Produktionsstätte
von Hasan Usta.
Und da muss man dazu sagen
– ich bin da auch echt verdammt stolz drauf
und es macht mehr sehr glücklich.
Denn er hat hier in der Stadt İznik
einfach noch diesen Raum mieten können,
diesen und auch das Atelier,
– das zeige ich euch auch gleich –
weil er einfach unsere Aufträge bekommen hat.
Und er meinte zuerst, dass er hier den Dreh machen möchte,
weil er es hier sauberer und schöner findet.
Aber, als wir dann gesehen haben,
dass er draußen in der Natur
an diesem wunderschönen Ort auch produziert,
haben wir gesagt: "Komm. Nee, nee, nee.
Wir gehen raus in die Natur. Da ist es viel, viel schöner."
Ich bin auch echt glücklich,
dass wir den ganzen Morgen dort verbracht haben.
Ich glaube, ihr habt jetzt auch schon mal gesehen,
– wir haben die Flaschen noch nicht einmal bemalt,
noch nicht einmal glasiert –
wie viele Arbeitsschritte bis jetzt schon nötig waren.
Die Flaschen waren jetzt schon im Ofen, sind gebrannt.
Jetzt werde ich sie innen einmal glasieren,
damit sie eben auch die Lebensmittel nicht aufsaugen,
sondern das Ganze wie so eine Schutzschicht bildet.
Und der Ton und auch die Glasur ist alles lebensmittelecht.
Das haben wir uns alles zertifizieren lassen.
Und nach der Innenglasur geht es direkt an den Maltisch.
Und ich dachte eigentlich, bevor ich hier bin,
dass das Malen so mein großes
– also meine große Leidenschaft wird.
Aber ich muss sagen, dass die Produktion bisher,
so diese Formgebung
– das war auch schon richtig schön.
Und jetzt bin ich mal auf das Malen gespannt.
Jetzt sind wir hier im Atelier
und werden die Flaschen bemalen.
Und bei den Designs
mussten wir uns natürlich auf ein paar festlegen.
Wir haben auch diese Flaschen hier.
Und die sind wirklich wunderschön.
Jede einzelne Flasche hier ist handbemalt.
Aber natürlich würde so eine Flasche
einfach auch zu viel kosten.
Man muss sagen...
>> MURAT: Ja, die schaffen nur am Tag fünf Flaschen,
wenn sie so ein Design machen würden.
>> SALLY: Pro Person sogar nur eine.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Teilweise,
je nachdem, wie aufwändig das Design ist.
Und wir haben uns jetzt für ein Design entschieden, was
wunderschön ist, was aber eben auch so herstellbar ist,
dass man eben mehrere Flaschen am Tag schafft,
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: sodass ihr alles was vom Olivenöl
natürlich abbekommen könnt.
Und deswegen machen wir jetzt
einfach ein paar schöne Farben.
>> MURAT: Ich finde das übrigens auch voll cool
als Paartherapie. Weißt du das?
>> SALLY: Ich habe dir das gerade gesagt.
>> MURAT: Nein, ohne Spaß.
>> SALLY: Jetzt hat er meinen Witz geklaut.
>> MURAT: Also mal wirklich so was vielleicht auch
mal zu Hause zu machen, das ist bestimmt
was ganz, ganz Cooles, wenn wir das machen.
>> SALLY: Ja. Ich finde das auch schön.
>> MURAT: Ein Kurs wäre cool, so was.
>> SALLY: Ja, so als Kurs
fände ich es auch richtig cool.
>> MURAT: Ich könnte das mal als Kurs anbieten.
>> SALLY: Das hat was total Meditatives.
[Musik]
Ich habe den Murat auch noch nie so konzentriert gesehen.
>> MURAT: Ja. Weißt du, wie viel Spaß das macht?
[Musik]
Jetzt nehme ich einfach hier einen Strich
bei 4,5 cm.
Ich brauche kein Metermaß, ich sehe das dann.
Und jede Flasche ist ein Unikat.
Also jede Flasche ist einfach anders.
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Du machst das super, Murat.
>> MURAT: Ja, normalerweise braucht man Schleifpapier.
Aber ich kann das mit meinen Händen machen.
Da merkt man halt,
was du vorher schon für Bauarbeiterhände hast.
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Jetzt haben wir schon
ziemlich viele Designs gemacht.
Und ich muss auch echt sagen,
also ich persönlich könnte ich mich jetzt nicht entscheiden,
welches das schönste ist.
>> MURAT: Ja, ich bin immer noch an dem grünen dran.
>> SALLY: Und jetzt mache ich noch
eine ganz besondere Farbe
und zwar Rainbow.
Und das erfordert ziemlich viel Geduld
und viele Farben.
>> MURAT: Ja.
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Gefällt mir richtig gut.
>> MURAT: Cool!
Guck mal, ich habe dir eine sauber gemacht.
>> SALLY: Sehr schön!
>> MURAT: Noch Gelb fehlt, gell?
>> SALLY: Komm, eine gelbe mache ich noch.
Und dann reicht es.
>> MURAT: Okay.
[Musik]
>> SALLY: 14 verschiedene Designs haben wir jetzt gemacht.
Und die werden jetzt von den Damen und Herren hier
einfach produziert.
Und ich muss dazu sagen,
was wir auch heute mitbekommen haben:
Es kann jetzt auch passieren,
dass ich diese Flaschen in den Ofen stecke zum Brennen
und dann ist die Farbe einfach weg.
So ist es nämlich gerade mit dem Rosa passiert.
Also da muss man ein bisschen experimentieren.
>> MURAT: Es waren 700 Flaschen.
Also sie haben die reingeschoben
und plötzlich war die Farbe weg.
>> SALLY: Ja, 700 Flaschen, einfach die Farbe weg.
Und das ist natürlich ziemlich schade,
weil viel Handarbeit drinnen steckt.
Und diese Flaschen bekommen jetzt eine Glasur,
damit sie außen eben auch schön glänzen
und zum einen wieder den Schutz bekommen,
nicht mehr matt sind.
Und dann kommen sie in den Backofen.
Bei 1020°C werden sie gebrannt.
Da brennt natürlich alles weg, was nicht zur Flasche gehört.
Danach werden sie gereinigt
und direkt nach Aydın geschickt,
wo unser Olivenöl reingefüllt wird.
Und ich habe mir jetzt gedacht,
weil diese 14 hier von mir handbemalt sind
mit Murat natürlich,
>> MURAT: Ja, meine ist die wertvollste übrigens.
>> SALLY: werde ich die jetzt signieren.
Und dann können wir die ja am Ende einfach schön verlosen.
>> MURAT: Ja.
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Ich habe euch ja schon zu Beginn
erklärt und erzählt, dass Olivenöl leider
zu den am meisten gefälschten Lebensmitteln der Welt gehört.
Wenn ihr zum Beispiel im Supermarkt steht,
dann könnt ihr auch selber wirklich darauf achten,
wie gut und wie qualitativ hochwertig euer Olivenöl ist.
Wenn ihr eine Olivenölflasche habt
und da steht drauf "Olivenöl aus der EU",
könnt ihr zumindest davon ausgehen,
dass es einfach billig zusammengepanschtes Olivenöl ist,
was wirklich eingekauft wurde
aus vielen europäischen Ländern.
Und da muss nicht mal 100% Olivenöl drin stecken.
Also wir haben uns damals, weil wir uns wirklich
sehr dafür interessieren seit zwei, drei Jahren,
weil wir auch unsere eigene Landwirtschaft
mittlerweile machen mit unserer Aquaponik,
sehr für Olivenöl interessiert
und sind dann auf einen Beitrag gestoßen vom Marktcheck.
Den können wir euch auch wirklich empfehlen.
>> MURAT: Genau. Schaut den unbedingt an,
unten in der Infobox.
Das ist ein Hammerbeitrag,
wo eigentlich das ganze Spiel mit dem Olivenöl
komplett aufgedeckt wird.
Und dadurch sind wir eigentlich
– waren wir echt richtig erschrocken.
>> SALLY: Ja. Und dadurch sind wir auch dazu gekommen,
unser Olivenöl selbst zu machen.
Und ich glaube, der Murat kann das auch ganz gut erklären
und so ein bisschen mit der Weinproduktion vergleichen.
>> MURAT: Und zwar
– ich bin selber kein Weintrinker,
aber ich habe Freunde, die Winzer sind,
sehr, sehr gute Freunde.
Gruß geht raus.
Auf jeden Fall ist das so:
Es gibt ja verschiedene Rebsorten.
Also es gibt über 1000 verschiedene Rebsorten.
Dann gibt es verschiedene Weinanbaugebiete.
Man würde
– ein Winzer würde zum Beispiel niemals
einen schwäbischen Wein nehmen und einen badischen Wein,
den zusammenmixen und ihn dann als Rotwein verkaufen.
Weil jede Region hat seinen eigenen Geschmack.
Auch beim Olivenöl ist es genau das Gleiche.
Also jede Region, jedes Land
hat seinen eigenen Geschmack, seine Besonderheit.
Und selbst in einer Region gibt es Unterschiede.
Wir sind jetzt hier in Aydın.
Zum Beispiel schmeckt das Olivenöl
in den Tiefebenen völlig anders
als das Olivenöl aus den Hochebenen.
Das ist einfach, von der Sonne her,
von der Vegetation her
sind da krasse Unterschiede im Geschmack.
Deswegen würde man niemals etwas mischen.
Und zwar ein richtiges Olivenöl
kommt nur aus einem Hain.
Man sagt im Türkischen Tek Bahçe dazu.
Tek Bahçe heißt "aus einem Garten".
Und es kommt aus einer Stadt.
Also eine Stadt, ein Garten ist perfekt.
Wenn es nicht perfekt ist,
dann heißt es nur noch eine Stadt.
Und dann heißt es nur noch ein Land.
Und nicht hier kreuz und quer,
da, wo es am billigsten ist.
>> SALLY: Und ich meine, man muss ja echt dazu sagen:
Es gibt auch supertolles Olivenöl in Italien
und auch in Griechenland.
>> MURAT: Die Griechen machen auch super Olivenöl.
>> SALLY: Und auch in dem Beitrag, den wir gesehen haben,
war es wirklich auch so,
dass ein italienischer Olivenbauer gesagt hat:
"Ich kann mein Olivenöl..."
>> MURAT: "Ich kann es gar nicht unter 17 € anbieten."
Das hat er knallhart gesagt.
Schaut euch das Video an!
Das ist ein ganz krasses Video.
>> SALLY: Und wir haben uns natürlich
hier für die Türkei entschieden,
weil wir türkische Wurzeln haben.
Und unsere Olivenhaine, die sind ganz oben da auf dem Berg.
>> MURAT: Der Vorteil ist auf dem Berg,
– die Olivenbauern auf Kreta können das bestätigen.
Und zwar das Tolle ist:
Wenn die Oliven sehr, sehr hoch sind,
also auf dem Berg sind,
da kommen weniger Schädlinge.
Das heißt, der größte Schädling für Oliven
ist eigentlich die Olivenfliege
und die fliegt einfach nicht so hoch
und ist da einfach nicht mehr da.
Man muss weniger spritzen und weniger düngen.
Das ist auch ganz, ganz wichtig.
Und...
>> SALLY: Und die haben da oben
– die haben diese tolle Wärme,
aber sie gehen nicht ein in der Sonne,
weil da oben einfach immer ein frischer Wind weht.
>> MURAT: Genau.
>> SALLY: Und das war doch früher
– war da nicht...
>> MURAT: Genau. Und da war ein Kohlewerk früher.
Das heißt, der ganze Boden, der ist eigentlich
– man sagt kontaminiert dazu
mit dem Kohleabbau.
Und da sind so viele Mineralien im Boden.
Und das ist natürlich gut für die Umwelt.
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Wir sind jetzt wieder zurück in Aydın,
wo eben das Olivenöl gepresst wurde,
zurück mit unseren wunderschönen Flaschen aus İznik.
Und die sind echt der Hammer!
Also jede einzelne Flasche ist wirklich der Wahnsinn!
Und jetzt wird hier unser Olivenöl abgefüllt.
>> SALLY: Şışeler geldi.
>> MAHMUT: Evet.
>> SALLY: Yağ dolduracağız.
>> MAHMUT: Yağ dolduracağız.
>> SALLY: Nasıl dolacak?
>> MAHMUT: Normalde biz modern teknıklerle
dolumu yapıyorduka, ama
bu el yapımı ağırlıkları sabiti
çok zor doldurması.
Sen istedin, lütfen sen de olursun gayet iyidir.
Bye!
>> SALLY: Ben mi dolduracağım?
>> MAHMUT: Yağ kepçe.
>> SALLY: Burda?
>> MAHMUT: Evet.
>> SALLY: 500 mililitre?
>> MAHMUT: 455 gram.
>> SALLY: Tamam.
>> MAHMUT: Birazdan fazla koy garanti olsun.
>> MAHMUT: Seni sen de güveniyorum sana.
>> SALLY: Okay.
Sonra görüşürüz.
Okay. Also
normalerweise benutzt der Mahmut immer Glasflaschen.
Und bei Glasflaschen ist es ja wirklich so, die sind genormt
und gehen dann auch durch die Anlage, durch eine Maschine.
Und da wird das Olivenöl maschinell abgefüllt.
Da wir uns aber für die Keramikflasche entschieden haben
und jede Flasche so individuell ist,
– das heißt, jede Flasche wiegt auch was anderes
und die sind auch zu groß für die Anlage –
muss ich sie hier jetzt alle per Hand abfüllen.
Er hat gesagt: "Ihr habt es mir eingebrockt,
also füll deine Flaschen selber ab."
Prof. Dr. Frau Özcan ist bereit.
Und jetzt werden die Flaschen mit 500 ml Olivenöl befüllt.
[Musik]
>> MURAT: So. Sally hat ja jetzt
die Flaschen hygienisch verschlossen.
Was sie euch aber noch nicht gezeigt hat, ist:
Und zwar der Verschluss ist ganz einfach so.
Der hat noch einen perfekten Dosierer,
einen perfekten Ausgießer.
Das heißt, wenn ihr die Flaschen nachher zu Hause benutzt
und sie mal ausgießt,
dass wirklich nicht auf einmal alles rauskommt
und auch nicht zu wenig,
sondern wirklich ein perfekter Verschluss.
Dann haben wir hier einen Holzdeckel drauf.
So.
Damit hat die Sally jetzt diese Flasche zugemacht.
Und jetzt nehmen wir diesen Schrumpfkopf.
Also so, wie halt der Güni halt ist, ein Schrumpfkopf.
Da nimmt man halt hier das Ding drüber.
Das sieht jetzt ein bisschen blöd aus,
muss ich ehrlich zugeben.
Und zwar muss man den jetzt so drüberziehen.
Das ist der hygienische Verschluss.
Und wenn ich das gemacht habe,
dann nehme ich den Superpower Bosch 3000 Heißluftföhn
und warte, bis er heiß wird.
Der wird gleich heiß.
Wahnsinn! Ein wahnsinniges Gerät!
Und jetzt tue ich gerade das da hier
kurz dranhalten.
Dann verschweißt das nämlich.
Und damit hört es jetzt aber nicht auf.
Und zwar
kommt noch das hier drüber.
Hier sind ein paar Informationen zum Öl.
Lest sie euch mal durch.
Mit Nährwertangaben und allem Drum und Dran
und die Geschichte über unser Olivenöl.
Und dann ist hier noch dieses Nazar Boncuk dran.
Und zwar kennt ihr vielleicht den Spruch: "Mach kein Auge."
"Mach kein Auge" heißt eigentlich...
Das soll dich vor bösen Blicken schützen.
Das heißt, das ist so ein tolles Olivenöl
und da soll nichts dran passieren.
Und deswegen machen wir ein Nazar Boncuk noch dran
und zwar hier.
Und das ist alles so richtig mitgedacht.
So.
Und das ist jetzt meine persönliche Post an euch.
Jetzt nehme ich diese Flasche hier.
So. Das ist der Karton.
Auch alles komplett natürlich.
Und ich muss euch ganz ehrlich sagen:
Hier ist kein einziges Plastikteil dran,
kein einziges Kunststoffteil,
nur leider
– es geht aber nicht anders.
Das ist dieser Stöpsel hier,
der hier.
Der sieht aus wie so ein Finger.
Da geht es leider nicht anders.
Ansonsten ist alles aus Holz.
Null Plastik wäre perfekt gewesen,
aber es ist einfach nicht möglich.
So.
Jetzt nehme ich hier diese Flasche.
Jetzt tue ich die Flasche hier reinfüllen.
Ihr seht, es ist saumäßig viel Handarbeit.
Diesen Brief, den schiebe ich euch auch noch rein.
So.
Äh, ich meine nicht euch, sondern der Flasche.
Und...
Und jetzt
– guck mal, Josh, das ist so einfach.
Zack, raus.
Einknicken.
So.
Das hält die Flasche jetzt richtig fest im Karton drin.
Und hier haben wir noch ein paar coole Sprüche für euch.
So.
Zu.
>> SALLY: Du darfst nur nicht vergessen:
Unser Chiliöl, das haben wir hier in den roten Flaschen.
Also wir haben
– alle 13 anderen Flaschen
sind mit unserem ganz normalen Olivenöl gefüllt.
Und die Chili-Olivenöle
haben wir hier in die roten Flaschen gefüllt.
Also die bitte nicht hier reinpacken, okay?
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Weil da müssen wir extra draufschreiben: "Scharf!"
>> SALLY: Dann packe ich sie wieder zurück.
Dann machen wir die zum Schluss, ja?
>> MURAT: Okay.
>> SALLY: Okay. Soll ich dir helfen?
>> MURAT: Nein, lass mich einfach in Ruhe bitte.
>> SALLY: Machst du das alleine?
>> MURAT: Ja, ich mache das alleine.
>> SALLY: Wirklich?
>> MURAT: Ja, ich habe es auch alleine auf die Welt geschafft.
Da habe ich dich auch nicht gebraucht.
Also lass mich das alleine machen.
Mach nicht so schnell.
Wir sind auf der Arbeit, nicht auf der Flucht.
>> SALLY: Du hast doch gesagt, wir müssen fertig werden.
>> MURAT: Ja, aber du übertreibst gerade deine Rolle.
>> SALLY: Bist du bereit?
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Gib es da...
>> MURAT: Der war lustig.
>> SALLY: Gibt es da auch eine Rückwärtstaste?
>> MURAT: Nein, da gibt es keine Rückwärtstaste.
Hör auf jetzt, Witze zu machen. Beeil dich.
>> SALLY: Es gab doch mal diese Serie:
"Liebling, ich habe die Kinder geschrumpft".
>> MURAT: Ja.
Auf geht's!
>> SALLY: Liebling, ich habe dich geschrumpft.
>> MURAT: Ihr seht, auch beim Flaschenbefüllen
ist es eine Mordsarbeit.
Aber es ist einfach was Besonderes.
Und wenn man das Ding schon in der Hand hält
und das nach Hause bekommt
oder das als Geschenk bekommt,
sagt man sich: "Krass! Was ist denn das?"
Und hier auf der Verpackung auch seht ihr:
Wir wurden ja schon zweimal ausgezeichnet
oder sogar dreimal ausgezeichnet
und haben dreimal Gold bekommen,
weil wir es in Israel
bei einem Riesenwettbewerb eingeschickt haben.
Und wir haben schon wirklich dreimal Gold bekommen
und einmal in der Kategorie sogar als Bester,
das Chiliöl zum Beispiel.
Und jetzt nehmen wir das gerade hierhin
und tun es in die Kartons reinfüllen.
>> SALLY: Jetzt hat er die ganze Zeit gesagt,
er ist viel schneller ohne mich.
Dann lasse ich ihn jetzt allein mit dem Verpacken.
Murat,
ich gehe schon mal nach Mannheim zurück
und du kannst hier weiter fertig verpacken.
>> MURAT: Ja.
Wir sehen uns dann
– was haben wir für ein Jahr? 2020.
2022 komme ich dann auch hinterher.
>> SALLY: Okay, ich helfe dir noch ein bisschen.
Und dann sehen wir uns in Mannheim,
wenn wir wieder zurück in Deutschland sind.
[Musik]
Aus Aydın direkt nach Mannheim.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Jetzt haben wir hier unser Olivenöl eingeräumt
>> SALLY: und dekoriert.
Guckt einmal her!
Und ja, jetzt seht ihr mal,
wie viel Arbeit und wie viel Handarbeit vor allem auch
in unserem Olivenöl steckt
und nicht nur im Olivenöl, sondern auch in der Flasche
und wie viel Herzblut wir auch reingesteckt haben.
>> MURAT: Also das ist nicht nur bei Olivenöl,
sondern allgemein bei...
>> SALLY: Bei allem.
>> MURAT: Bei den landwirtschaftlichen Erzeugnissen
sieht man eigentlich nie, wie viel Arbeit dahintersteckt.
Wir haben hier jetzt ein ehrliches Olivenöl gemacht
ohne Tricks,
ohne Färben, ohne irgendwas.
>> SALLY: 100% Olivenöl aus der Frühernte.
Und es ist ein wirklich superhochwertiges Produkt.
Ich hoffe, dass ihr es auch wertschätzt,
genauso wie wir es wertschätzen.
>> MURAT: Genau. Weil normalerweise
wird ja aus der Frühernte nicht verkauft.
Wir haben es ja vorher schon gesagt, du musst es...
>> SALLY: Das ist zu wertvoll.
>> MURAT: Das ist, weil es einfach zu wertvoll ist.
Weil, wenn das länger hängen bleibt,
dann hast du das Dreifache.
Wir haben jetzt hier nur das Einfache.
Das spiegelt sich dann natürlich auch im Preis wider.
Aber
es war nie die Intention, das billigste Olivenöl zu machen,
sondern das beste Olivenöl.
>> SALLY: Genau.
Und jetzt haben wir das hier in Mannheim schon eingeräumt.
Also ab heute gibt es das auch hier in Mannheim,
aber auch bei uns im Onlineshop.
Und falls ihr aus der Umgebung kommt,
könnt ihr sogar in Mannheim das Olivenöl probieren.
>> MURAT: Genau. Probiert es aus!
>> SALLY: Also einmal...
Wir haben jetzt hier alle Flaschen.
Das Einzige ist natürlich, das rote ist das Chili-Olivenöl.
Das dürft ihr auch gern probieren.
Also alle Mutigen unter euch,
probiert ruhig auch mal Chili-Olivenöl.
Ja, ich hoffe, dass euch das Video gefallen hat.
Wir verlosen ja noch unsere Olivenölflaschen,
die handsignierten.
Aber ich würde sagen,
wir verlosen heute einfach drei Flaschen.
Und ich denke, wenn ihr unter dieses Video schreibt,
was so die drei besonderen Merkmale sind
von unserem Olivenöl...
>> MURAT: Ja. Es gibt mehrere besondere Merkmale,
aber nennt uns mal drei Stück.
>> SALLY: Ja, einfach drei,
drei Fakten, warum unser Olivenöl so toll ist
und so besonders ist.
Dann schreibt es gerne unten in die Kommentare.
Das Gewinnspiel läuft jetzt einfach für eine Woche.
Und dann werden wir per Los die Gewinner ziehen.
Natürlich die mit den richtigen Antworten.
>> MURAT: Genau.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Echt cool!
Ich möchte wieder in die Türkei zurück.
>> MURAT: Liebe Grüße an die Menschen aus Aydın
und vielen, vielen Dank!
>> SALLY: Und İznik.
>> MURAT: Und wie gesagt,
wenn es ausverkauft ist, ist es ausverkauft.
Wir können da nicht mehr nachliefern.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Dann gibt es halt zur nächsten Ernte wieder
und fertig.
>> SALLY: Genau. Jetzt Olivenölernte 2020 ist jetzt da.
Und dann mal schauen, was nächstes Jahr passiert.
Also macht's gut!
>> MURAT: Macht's besser!
>> SALLY: Und bis zum nächsten Mal!
Tschüss!
>> MURAT: Tschau!
[Musik]